hello everyone this next game I'm going
to show you was played in 2007 in
Barcelona in the Casino de Royale and it
was played between well Michael cross n
co and Hikaru Nakamura
kreschenko is white and Nakamura is
black and although crossing Kovas from
Moscow is actually a Polish Grandmaster
he's a noted writer and a chess trainer
and he is considered to be one of the
strongest Polish grandmasters since the
World War two and he's a very very
aggressive player and he won numerous
awards for his style of play and for
four best games so as usual it's always
an interesting game when to aggressive
players meet and like I said this was
played in 2007 so Nakamura is 20 years
old here but as you'll see he was
already quite the demon so krosang Cove
is white and he plays Knight to f3 and
Nakamura plays Knight to f6
we have c4 sort of an English opening
e6g 3d5
Bishop to g2 Bishop e7 a crescendo
castles Nakamura castles b3 we have a
five-night Knight to c3 trying to
provoke d4 but Nakamura isn't interested
he plays C 6 so we have d4 Knight B to
d7 Queen to c2 Nakamura goes b6 e for
now and Nakamura plays Bishop to a6 we
have a knight to D to c5 by nakamura he
captures on b5 and nakamura places c c
capture 74 and in this position cross
think of play tonight to b5 already
interested in creating some
complications so let's see what happens
if if Nakamura would accept this knight
on d5 if Bishop captures on b5
you would get D gastrous on e6 and this
would open up the attack from the bishop
to the rook on a 8 so something like
rook to see a would be played a he
captures on b7 attacking the rook and
after Queen captures on g7 night to f3
just going for that isolated d4 pawn we
would tell D 3 point 2 b1 and now this
bishop
has to move because he is still attacked
by the c4 pawn so we would have Bishop
to a6 and now 95 attacking the Queen and
crossing code would win the d3 pawn so
it's a kind of a sneaky variation but
Nakamura doesn't go for this
so after night the b5 Nakamura plays he
captures on d5 and here crescendo plays
Knight to d4 so we have a roof to c8 by
Nakamura just putting that rook on a
nice file in front of the Queen
we have rook to e1 and now nakamura
plays B 5 so we have Bishop to b2 rook
to e8 Queen to d1 getting the Queen out
of that pin we have big captures on c4 b
casters on c4 Queen to b6 and now rook
to be one crossing Kove plays rugby one
to protect the bishop and two you know
her as the Queen a bit but here he
allows D captures in c4 and Nakamura
winds up on here but the crescendo had a
sneaky idea he played a Knight to c6 and
now this is a very dangerous line you
see because if the knight is captured
which Nakamura played Nakamura played
rook captures on c6 now % KO plays
Bishop captures on f6 and cross Senko
was probably very happy about this
Bishop captures on f6 idea because he
opened the attack on the blacks Queen
you as you can see here he also has this
attack on the rook on c6 and he also has
a double attack on the bishop on e7 and
the naturally one would think that this
is crushing for white but the demon
Nakamura had had a different idea and
Nakamura plays Queen captures on f2 with
check and I'm pretty sure that well this
was quite a shock for chrushank Oh such
an aggressive player missing this kind
of move so he has to capture King
captures on f2 and Nakamura plays Bishop
to c5 check so the King has to go up can
get three and now Nakamura captures the
bishop on f6 again which check rook
captures on f6 so we have Kings to g4
and now Knight to e5 check press n go
plays King to g5 and we have root 2 G 6
check
King to h5 and now f6 this s6 is a very
nice move it protects the knight on e5
and is also covering up the g5 squares
so now nakamura is actually threatening
route to h6 checkmate
so crescendo tries to defend this by
rook captures on e5 and a Kimura place
ro captures on e5 would check we have
king to h4 and here nakamura plays
Bishop to c8 and in this position the
Polish Grandmaster resigned and what's
going on in this position well nakamura
is again threatening to play a rock h6
checkmate and whatever move white plays
will let's say one of the defense could
be like g4 you would get a bishop to f2
check and a Turk engage three again well
you get this rook to h5 checkmate a very
nice
checkmate indeed because rook can be
captured as the point is pin from the
bishop and c8 so yeah very nice game by
Nakamura against such an aggressive
player who had some pretty good ideas
and Nakamura also won this tournament
with seven of the nine points and yeah a
very nice game by the young demon so
that's what the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
and as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thanks to
everyone who contributed to my channel I
would like to thank in this video Jared
Lingam Dan o'hanlan
Don Dugan and red labyrinth thank you
guys and thank you everyone either if
you're just watching the videos
commenting even maybe sharing on some
social networks it really does mean a
lot for the promotion of my channel so
yeah that's it and I will see you soon
bye guys